das kitz und herzlich willkommen zu
diesem kleinen ingo video
ich wollte euch nur bescheid geben dass
die roten blocks ab dem 29
also ab übermorgen kommen wachsende
anzahl ist der posten des wie donnerstag
den 9 20 uhr samstag ab dann kommen die
rutsche videos wieder regelmäßig weil
wir dann eine möglichkeit haben werden
die hochzuladen
jetzt für euch schon mal eine kleine
challandes war machen wir ein
gewinnspiel wer von euch kann erwarten
wo ich jetzt gerade natürlich zeit
mitbringt schreibe es in die kommentare
der genaue standort also der am nächsten
dran ist an meinem eigenen standort
gewinn und trägt auf jeden fall
erwähnung in dem nächsten blog und
vielleicht eine andere kleinigkeit also
rat fleißig die keinen tipp vom 2 ein
360 grad kamera schwenkt
jetzt
das war eine sehr aus wie beschränken
sollten genug sein
ja ich werde schauen dass max morgen
vielleicht ein video hochlädt
vielleicht noch ein game video dann
sehen wir uns am 29
wieder mit rot videos christen machen
wollte